hey you know if you're wondering what
happened to all the crime since November
8th you're actually bringing up a very
interesting question Fox news stories
about violent crime are down 50 percent
since the November 8th midterm election
there's a very good research piece from
Media Matters Fox's coverage of violent
crime dropped after the midterms weekday
violent crime segments decreased by 50
percent in the week of the election
compared to the weekly average since
Labor Day are any of us surprised in
fact Fox News decreased stories about
violent crime 63 percent
Media Matters has the details this is
not unique I assure you to Fox News we
all knew in the lead up to the November
8th midterms that there's stories about
violent crime which of course ignore
that by the way stories about violent
crime in what they call Democrat cities
not only ignore the facts of for example
on a crime rate basis Oklahoma is more
dangerous than New York State and on a
crime rate basis both property and
violent crime Oklahoma City is more
dangerous than New York City remember
rates a lot more people live in New York
City aside from the fact that it's an
absurd narrative
and that most cities in general are run
by democrats because more Democrats tend
to live in cities we also know that it's
just a ploy and I want to remind you I'm
going to give you other examples all of
which I have previously covered because
they do this all the time in 2014 it was
Ebola remember the guy who went ebolaing
at Brooklyn Bowl and at the time I was
like at Brooklyn Bowl the day after and
I was worried that I get Ebola what's
going on anyway 2014. we knew leading up
to the midterms that Ebola was being
used by people like Rand Paul stands out
and many others just to criticize Barack
Obama that's all that it was they just
wanted to criticize Obama Obama and even
though there were like
four cases
and the one person that died got Ebola
outside of the country if I recall I
mean it was crazy
and the day after the 2014 midterms no
more talk about ebola and it never came
back they never talked about it again
another example this is a classic the
migrant Caravan coverage this one was in
2018 leading up to the 2018 midterms
under Donald Trump the migrant Caravans
are on the way they're coming they're
coming here and we know that migrant
Caravans tell us oh there's an election
coming up and of course as is reported
here migrant Caravan coverage plummeted
after the midterms and indeed it did and
also a piece from Vox Fox News barely
mentions Caravan first morning after
midterms Fox and Friends had been just
ranting and ranting and ranting about
Caravans day after the midterms they
quite literally still have the election
results up on the screen this was the
date this was November
6th or 7th 2018 when whenever
um and they barely talk about it we know
the story we know exactly what they do
it's very clear at this point remember
not to follow it and ask yourselves the
question not fall for it ask yourself
the question is this cutting coverage
because it's important is this getting
coverage because it's accurate or is
this getting coverage because it serves
a political goal or a media goal which
can often be creating fear and
titillating and scaring viewers if you
ask those questions you figure these out
pretty quickly
if you have a friend or loved one who is
passionate about the environment here is
a perfect holiday gift our sponsor
established titles is a project that
lets you ceremonially purchase as little
as one square foot of dedicated land in
edelston Scotland so that you can call
yourself a lord or a lady like the
historic Scottish tradition some people
even change their plane tickets or
credit cards to include Lord or lady
your title pack comes with an official
certificate you can see exactly where
your plot of land is located it makes a
perfect last minute gift but most
importantly established titles plants
one free tree for every plot of land
sold established titles does really good
work all over the world with
reforestation organizations like one
tree planted and trees for the future so
you'll have a great laugh whether you're
Scottish or not I'm not but you're
giving the gift gift of reforestation to
fight climate change if you use my link
you'll get 10 percent off and your plot
of land will be right next to mine you
can see it on a map go to established
titles.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for an extra 10 off on top of
their Black Friday deal the link is down
below